[Music]
welcome
to another episode of lawyer yeah reddit
reacts
i like when you watch the pictures and
it goes ha ha
all right here's the intro
yeah yeah copyright there jacksfields
please don't please for the love god
jack's films could steal a million
a million pounds of revenue in copyright
for taking his
name oh god jax films
please sweden has the best action movies
fight me oh yeah
this is an old classic isn't it is it a
classic i haven't heard about this movie
in so long
this is like uh i went out two thousands
i think it was called cops joseph fires
i recognize that
oh yeah he made yellow and wait what he
made a way out
the game by swedish born in lebanon
oh wait wait wait wait wait
holy [ __ ] my mind is blown right now
that's the guy
that went you oscars i hate you oscars
[ __ ] fear
oh my god that's him he's swedish
african legend
you know and it's coming soon right yeah
it's kind of i'm talking too long that's
okay
it's like no it's like we got a long
show judge we gotta be fair to everybody
let me continue a little bit this is my
time to shine man i don't know
you flew all the way i know you did yeah
all right
if you keep talking we're not going to
be able to get to the game
[Music]
wait so he made cops they're all in
swedish movie that's hilarious
what the [ __ ] what a career wait so he
also made uh
brothers a tale of two uh brothers that
was an amazing game
i respect it i respect it yo wanna
collab
did he actually post on the reddit
oh god wait that was 28 days ago
are you serious i didn't see this
i left him hanging carson i'm sorry hey
it's gaming month let's play tetris
that's your game right
how do i get in touch with carson i
don't know i'll follow you on instagram
uh cara delevingne came up first i'm
sorry so that's why he tweets all this
weird [ __ ]
i've been ignoring him it all makes
sense
british people be like cookies
biscuits petition to change in uk
cookies to biscuits come on can we get
it saw this on russell howard hour i'm
so proud of this community
the uk have proved they will buy
anything
this year tambourine sales have gone up
by 15
we did it
for those of you who who bought into the
tambourine stock market
i told you bro i told you i can't tell
if this is a randomized meme
how did this come about i am so confused
only 50
we got to do better those are rookie now
we're just getting started
listen this is nothing this is nothing
it's gonna skyrocket
just wait don't sell yet don't sell
trust me don't sell
public announcement any youtubers in uk
want to be in my next
music video sive let's go all right
nothing out of the ordinary here
just ahead simp in action let's move on
hey felix linguistic
trainer here the word can be split into
four parts
ne as in okay neck good yeah nick
glee as a glitch negli g
bull medley g bull that's it negligible
then put a j you dumb [ __ ] americans
a british
learn english god damn it that's not how
that's spelled negligible
negligible negligible i can say it thank
you linguistic trainer
negligible necklace
[Applause]
hell yeah thank you that was actually
really helpful [ __ ] look at your ball
shut the [ __ ] up shut up
shut up negligible
i got it my dad me acting cool in front
of my
crush your dad is so hot felix
that's how i do it this is me and then
they go oh your dad is so pretty
and cool wow oh okay so that's cool
handsome dad i love who's live in his
shade people who've never been
on the y me who has two times on the y
adam warlock 707 who has been on the y
18 18. seriously i don't even know who
you are
adam warlock but i think once you get to
which is the epic number of course i'll
make you a cake
adam i think that's only fair ever had
this happening to you
now imagine dropping her right now
uh you would die it would pay it would
go through your skull
covey 19 symptoms may include having
lack of takes people who actually like
jake paul videos
jake paul bad i mean he is bad what the
[ __ ] is he doing
girls with their pets oh my god your pet
hamster looks so cute oh my god yours
too let's take pictures of them
boys with their beds i have a hamster i
have a hedgehog let's race
the race will happen ksi my hedgehog is
faster than your hamster and you goddamn
knew it
stop pretending stop pretending like
yeah
bloody stupid in it having a hamster
felix cajellberg pewdiepie jack
sean cosplay split eyes
crazy stinky
yeah he keeps changing it's so confusing
i never call him sean
i know he makes sean cringe when i call
him sean hey sean i know you're watching
this
shawnee boy sean oh shani
i'll write you a song sean
[Music]
shawneel
channel
copyrighted don't ever ever
you said in your video sean because i
will strike them
pov pewdiepie down what are your meme
yep
what should cry i'm not logged in god
damn it
me can i go to the bathroom teacher it's
may
me no it's november oh good one
got him i thought this was a no-not joke
and i was like wait
what okay since i'm constantly sharing
cringy memories now
and that's the thing i remember this hit
me randomly a couple days ago
and i i remember dying a little bit
inside so you know yeah
sometimes you got a booger all right you
got a booger
and i'm pretending you don't booger i i
don't remember which grade it was
very low i probably was five or six but
i was like
i was getting annoyed by the fact that i
have to go to the bathroom to to
pick my nose right don't want to do that
waste of time
so i came up with this idea that if i do
like this
and i would do it in front of people too
like oh yeah
okay what the [ __ ] what was i doing
i was five or six i i thought okay
definitely not older
why did i share this i don't remember
when it's five days in the game in
december and no minecraft videos
uploaded
gaming month it's just getting started
we need to get
speed and momentum first come on
pewdiepie
felix cajellberg this is from the anime
seven deadly sins which i love
now smash like on this video if you like
seven daddy since two
yeah i definitely loved it find someone
who looks at you the way edgar looks
at felix oh he's so cute oh
edgy ah you look old now huh
and i said this before he's a mixed
color pug
he's always had those silvery patches
he's as a mix it's a rare
color okay he's rare he's a rare it's
like a rare pokemon
except this is one of those [ __ ] the
rare ones
like when you get a hollow and you're
like whoa that's gotta be worth so much
and then it's two dollars and you're
like oh
that's edgar okay
ksi and pewdiepie using the recorder and
outpouring to play our unrecognizable
celine dion cover
youtube copy strike we must take it oh
it wasn't youtube it's the company
it sells greedy companies i don't think
we made enough money on the celine dion
uh song soundtrack
should we test it all right right now i
am playing celine dion
heart will go on
wow wasn't that great strike me
i just want to see happen it's a social
experiment sorry i had something in my
mouth
2020 can't get any something get weird
sorry 2020 can't get any weirder right
25th december 2020 jesus christ jones
the battle
please jesus son we need you strongest
creatures and their weaknesses
uh oh okay now now we can see if i learn
something negligible
i learn i learn my brain absorb that
yeah and it's in here now locked and
loaded at any time
negligible
oh my god my test creations are so weird
also appears in photoshop all right
okay fair fair but at least i don't make
them into real life
that's a dangerous transition never make
your dream a reality
it's dangerous and often very ugly
on christmas day i'm gonna oh god no
take it away from me take it away from
me
[Music]
why should i summon her furby luckily i
have the defense
on christmas day i'm gonna give you the
best most
unexpected christmas present ever you
activating windows
ksi has an update at windows
cruise keysight computer part of button
that cringe
yo box office artist back at it again
that's my that's my gun then that's so
sick
they have a lunch that's so cool you
can't even see it
yeah that's dope thanks for doing it man
i actually have
uh this one colored painted so i can
make a gun
uh ikea gun them i just haven't had time
to build it but it's all painted
it's good to go it's gonna be sick maybe
i should build it on a livestream yeah i
can do that
american sweden we have the best action
movies
india oh come on just got nothing on
cops
oh hell yeah never mind
oh [ __ ] they added the text
what are you gonna do with that banana
he's just peeling it gotcha
off of [ __ ] sake goddamn all right
yes well done edgar well done you look i
got looking kind of
spicy i'll take it dude oh my god i
can't believe i didn't think of this
and you know what else i didn't think of
that latino attractiveness
is set around being macho muscular bras
chiseled man hey remember remember how
that chinese study said that attractive
men wears red
mind flip
[Music]
dale damn son where'd you find this
felix teacher after she saw she saw he
became pewdiepie
i whipped that boy's ass oh that reminds
me actually my mom sent me this
yesterday
you might think this is cringe i don't
care i think it's cool
in the school i went to the students
gets to
design the cover for the yearbook or
whatever you want to call it
someone drew me for the cover is that
is that true can someone confirm that's
so cool i always dreamed about
when i was a kid i was like that'd be so
cool to draw the cover and i never got
to do it
because only the the student that kisses
to the art teacher got to do it
oh yeah well done well done it's it's
absolutely stunning by the way
i don't know i think it's cool thank you
really funny and hysterical
we're gonna react to my old videos
workday with customers but at least have
time to watch some quality cars
what an audience what what what a
typical audience
oh no pewdiepie videos in the future
hell yeah
okay all right hi diggy
[Laughter]
we've seen water sheep but what about
lava sheep
i love him
if you're sad don't be sad people who
were said a minute ago
i say it before and i say it again if
you're sad
don't be sad being sad is bad
[Music]
you're welcome oh hell yeah got a
freaking samurai helmet hitting each
side
oh sick oh no way
bro we have too many armors maybe we can
make use of all of them
thank you guys so much huge peepee quinn
amazing god damn you guys are so
talented
that's so cool it's mirrored right yeah
huge peepee i'm not logged in but yeah
there it is hell yeah yeah
that looks sick she got the melon
texture so realistic too
swedish people naming their children all
right
okay that's just racist yeah
i said it that is so racist
i like it
i just told that for him for his head
shape
he should have a different haircut
that's all that's what i meant with that
god damn it you got to know your own
features and play to your strength
oh no way we got a [ __ ] iron man
glove
hell yeah oh what the [ __ ]
[ __ ] say why is this not getting more
upboards
ah that is actually really cool i like
the style of mars yeah
made this on paint with matte that's
actually pretty good
[Laughter]
i love when my random stories become a
meme that's exactly how i
imagine it in my head
look i told felix that i would if he
wants me to there's no pressure it's
whatever
i guess it just means that we're not
friends like i don't get the host meme
review show on his youtube channel
are we friend even friends at all does
that not count for something
god i'm gonna unfollow him on facebook
not facebook
boots yeah yeah i saw this
you'll never get the host whatever
helped me sean
yeah shawny on okay sean this is your
moment
i summon you
sean
[Music]
please host me murphy with me
together we want to run this galaxy when
you see someone from school in public
nice i'm glad that's two half split
second
half yeah made it into a meme very nice
oh my god all courses died
oh and someone animated the jaden bit
corpse guide
[Laughter]
listen you don't have to do this
i have a child you do have two children
i have
two child likes i forgot about it hey
listen
i'll just stay here and you just walk
away
you know i won't tell i won't tell
anyone i won't tell anyone
i swear all right i'll be back in in a
few minutes
still here okay i will be of course
thank you okay thank you so much damn
the frames
[Laughter]
amazing
[Music]
that was so funny i love that thing
there's 18
000 balls nice whoa holy [ __ ]
i love it
[Music]
holy sh god
damn that's like a professional ad what
the [ __ ] dude
frantic friends on instagram that
deserves a huge shout out
i'm not logged in but go follow why am i
not locked in on anything
god damn that's amazing and then we have
this
right underneath
is that no that is not blue shirt kid
yeah
blue shirt kid will become president i
know it
[Laughter]
they don't know that a swedish man
should have picked
oh they don't know and if only they knew
i love this meme it's an old one isn't
it it's super old i love how that's
getting popular
yeah they're getting too close dude it's
getting delayed because of covid i'm
it's so frustrating but it is happening
and they're afraid
they're afraid guys thank you for
watching another episode of the y
my favorite time of the week everyone's
favorite time of the week gaming month
is upon us
all right expect videos with games in
them yeah
here comes the outro
thanks for watching look at graph check
out base merch
my new brain and that's it brofist yeah
looking for some high level gaming gear
check out face
okay but of what top scientists have
determined
that wearing base gear makes you a
better gamer with at least
two percent basis for everyone no matter
what level you're at
but you need to be at least six eight to
order which i
am of course you have before december
11th to place your order
and solidify your place in the gaming
history books
so what are you waiting for buff up your
wardrobe today and head over to base.gg
basil i'm 6'8 i swear
in high order